it is looking like a merry christmas
already for some key trump political
allies
paul manafort who formerly ran the trump
2016 campaign
roger stone decades-long political
adviser to donald trump
both found themselves in legal hot water
because of their association
they have received full pardons this is
a wonderful mercy just days before
christmas
and the compassion it left could not be
more furious i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from henry knox
who says for covid we follow the science
what science
political science that's true that was
always true and actually
the comment is even more insightful than
it would seem
because the the left when they invoke
this term science
it is actually precisely because they
have defined their politics
as science because they've defined their
understanding as science this goes way
back about 150 years
and they continue to do it today and you
see it most clearly
with those little lab coat doctor
dictators who are telling us how to run
all of our lives
outside of the constitutional system
it's very bad not not making a lot of us
feel too well
this time of year but if you are
concerned about men's wellness you got
to check out
hymns 66 of men start to lose their hair
by age 35. once you've noticed thinning
hair it can be too late
the best way to prevent more hair loss
is to do something about it while you
still have some
hymns is helping guys be the best
version of themselves with
licensed medical providers and fda
approved products to help treat hair
loss
no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
or long pharmacy lines just answer a few
quick questions
a medical professional will review and
if they determine it's right for you
they can prescribe you
medication to treat hair loss that is
shipped directly to your door
listen i am not a hulking adonis of a
man necessarily i'm not
exactly an olympic athlete one thing i
always had going
for me though in the ladies department
was my hair
got good hair on both sides of the
family so look you want to keep it okay
we don't all have infinite resources
here hymns is giving you
their best offer yet today if you are
not happy with your results after 90
days hims will give you a full refund
and right now my listeners can get their
first visit
absolutely free go to forhims.com
knowles can wlas
that is for hims.com slash knowles
knwles
prescription products require an online
consultation with a healthcare provider
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate
restrictions apply see website full
details and important safety information
that is for hims.com knowles so you've
got to go check it out
wonderful wonderful product
president trump has pardoned these two
key political allies
i say good on him i think it's great
stone and manafort rogers both of these
guys actually have been
sort of legendary in conservative
political circles
and and i mean legendary in the full
sense of that word roger stone has
cultivated this image
that he's the sorcerer of the dark
political arts
he's a dirty trickster and some of that
really is
a legend of stone's own creation i think
you know some of it is just a way to
kind of gin up publicity
and but he's been involved in presidents
going back to richard nixon
ronald reagan uh and now most recently
donald trump
paul manafort two same thing they had a
firm together back in the old days
roger stone and paul manafort have no
doubt been involved in
shady business deals every
political operative has been involved in
shady business deals at least at that
level that's just
a occupational hazard or a requirement
of the job
but i think we all know the real reason
that stone and manafort were prosecuted
right it's because they committed
the one unforgivable crime they helped
the bad orange man get elected
they didn't get prosecuted because of
they put money in this account overseas
or they worked on this
particular business deal or they talked
to this witness or
that's not why they got prosecuted they
got prosecuted because they worked for
trump they'd been involved in shady
business deals
for decade upon decade upon decade the
only reason they came under fire why
because of the abuses at the the doj the
politicization
of our criminal justice system and they
worked for the bad orange man so i'm
glad
i'm glad that that trump pardoned them
when high level democratic operatives
are prosecuted at the same time with the
same ferocity
that these republican operatives are
just coincidentally the ones who worked
for trump
when that happens when tony podesta goes
to the can
then we can talk about how manafort and
stone should be prosecuted
until then i think this is a great idea
there is a reason that we have the
pardon power
i know we talk about law and order on
this show a lot
you have law order that's
extraordinarily important to a
civilization
the pardon power exists for a reason
because you you do want to have
an avenue for for mercy as well
now trump pardoned a lot of other people
i i haven't been thrilled with all of
trump's pardons going back years now
one i'm not thrilled with here is the
pardon of charles kushner who is his
son-in-law's father
who actually was prosecuted by chris
christie which shows you what a small
world it is
charles kushner first of all his crimes
were committed
outside of this political realm you know
his prosecution was not
selective for political reasons he
pled guilty to a whole host of sort of
financial and business charges
he tried to tamper with witnesses by
actually hiring a hooker
to seduce his sister's husband
and then he filmed it and he sent the
tape to his sister it was pretty
pretty shady stuff man pretty dark dark
stuff
and he does not have the same defense
that stone and manafort have
that because they had some political
courage to work for this guy they were
selectively prosecuted so i don't like
that one so much i don't like some of
the other pardons but in terms of the
two big ones that we're hearing about
today stone and manafort
great stuff aoc the compassionate left
winger
absolutely furious she tweets out a flow
of pardons
for the wealthy and the corrupt yet
brandon bernard
was left to die when his own jurors and
prosecutor begged for mercy
our carceral system in our prison system
laid bare for the world to see
brandon bernard was the guy he was on
he's been on death row for decades and
he was just executed a couple of weeks
ago
because trump is now actually enforcing
the law
brandon bernard the whole left said we
need to let this guy off the hook please
it's
a he's a black man that's racial
injustice he's been there for so long
it's more generalized injustice you've
got to let him off the hook
brandon bernard killed two youth pastors
in cold blood
after they had helped him he and a
couple of his criminal friends
took a ride from these youth pastors
held them at gunpoint
stuffed them in a trunk robbed them
drove around for hours tried to sell the
woman's wedding ring
they were pleading for mercy reading
them uh reading these killers scripture
another one of these guys shot them both
in the head the woman actually didn't
die
so brandon bernard poured gasoline all
over the car and
burned her alive and burned the body of
the other guy
that's the that's the crime that aoc
says he should have gotten off the hook
and stone and manafort helped
trump win an election and that's the
more egregious crime according to aoc
could you imagine
what a pervert you have to be to think
that can you imagine what a completely
upside down understanding of justice you
need to have to believe that
but that's aoc's understanding of
justice and and frankly it's
it's more widespread on the left aoc is
in many ways just a
loud speaker for for what people on the
far left and increasingly with people
more broadly on the left believe this
year
has clarified a lot you might say
hindsight is 20 20. wakka wakka
but it is it is this year this past four
years
have clarified a lot i think the most
important takeaway from especially this
year but i suppose the whole trump era
is that the left is not engaging in good
faith
the left has convinced us to play by
standards and rules that they themselves
flout and for some reason we've gone
along with it
this is one key sometimes you hear this
uh very famous sort of wicked
community organizer saul olinsky brought
up he wrote rules for radicals
he was an uh sort of mentor of hillary
clinton
and and most other left-wing organizers
and he said
the key is you've got to make your
opponents play by their own rules
and the left has not only done that
they've actually made us adopt certain
rules
that don't really make a whole lot of
sense that we previously wouldn't have
adopted
but they've made us forget about
political reality right which is that
politics does not just exist in this
abstract plane where it's only principle
and it's only these ideologies and five
maxims written down to explain your
whole view of the world
politics is circumstantial politics
requires that you adjust your strategy
based on how your opponent is playing
it's the same thing as war
right war is politics by other means
well the the re
your opponent has a say in both politics
and war and
what the we've been trying to live up to
this standard that we
at least thought that the left believed
in even though they didn't live up to it
standards of fairness statements of
justice science of equality standards of
non-discrimination
they don't they don't believe in that
okay
and so we've got to adjust our strategy
if we want any hope of
righting this ship not that we need to
commit immorality it's not that we need
to commit injustices but we need to
be clever you know you want to be wise
as a serpent innocent as a dove in terms
of these pardons i would oppose them
if the left were playing in good faith
if the left would also throw their guys
into the can but they won't do it
they're trying to impose radical new
standards on us and
we merely throw our hands up in the air
right not only that
we need to go further we need to
first of all start engaging in politics
we also
need to actively defend
our own standards i think this is to me
the biggest takeaway of 2020
and 2016 which is you've got
political correctness wokism this kind
of
now scientific tyranny technocratic
tyranny the fouchy types that you're not
allowed to see your family and christmas
gets canceled and you got to wear the
mask and you got to jump around on one
leg
and you've got that new standard put in
and
for decades now the right wing response
has been
you do you hey you do you i can't
question what you're doing i can't
suggest it's better to do one thing or
another
because the minute that i make a moral
claim then you can make a moral claim
and they're both the same thing so the
minute
the minute that i say don't go to drag
queen story hour maybe there shouldn't
be drag queen story hour
you can tell me not to go to church
the minute i tell you don't have drag
shows with nine-year-old boys
named desmond where men are throwing
dollar bills
at his feet at a strip or at a gay bar
rather which actually did happen
the minute i tell you you can't do that
then you're gonna tell me i can't go to
a restaurant
and we i don't know where we got it in
our head that that made any sense but it
doesn't
we have discernment we have faculties of
reason we have good judgment
we can say no one this thing is good
this thing is bad in fact not only can
we say that
we must say that that is what society
must do every society for all times has
had standards
we've had even on the topic of free
speech
i like i'd strongly defend the first
amendment our traditional american
understanding of free speech
there's still some things you're not
supposed to say some things you are and
what what the left has done is totally
flip it
and we've got to re-engage if we want
any hope of turning this ship around
we've got to re-engage there is a
governor
one governor at least in america who is
doing this who's asserting
a a serious standard he
understands how to protect his
constituents if you want to protect your
constituents namely your family
you got to check out rings it's doorbell
season the busiest time of year at your
front door
and that is absolutely true in my house
ring has everything you need
to keep an eye on your home this holiday
season and throughout the year
see and speak to whoever is at your door
from anywhere with video doorbells
you could have a package delivery guy
coming okay that's good to talk
maybe you've got your mother-in-law
visiting that then you definitely want
to know who's at the front door
so you can all stand perfectly still and
just wait
for the threat to pass help protect your
whole home with ring alarm a powerful
affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install
yourself i really like ring we've had
ring
really since the beginning of this show
and
it really just makes me feel great
especially when i travel to know that
sweet little alisa
my lovely wife can know who is outside
the door before
she opens the door for a limited time go
to ring dot com
slash no skin wles for special holiday
offers that is ring.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s you know all about
ring go check them out this is a great
time of year
to get it ron desantis down there in
florida
is first of all he's got a famously
elderly population there
because once you reach a certain age in
new york i think it is a
law you have to move to florida a lot of
people do this so he's got an
older population in florida they are far
at far greater risk for the coronavirus
than any
any of the younger people or the
essential workers or whatever
right it's this virus really does break
down a long age
mostly and but yet we're being told by
the left
no the way we've got to determine how to
give out the vaccine is not based on age
it's based on if you're black
if you're black you should get it if
you're white you shouldn't get it
seriously there were people talking
about this in the new york times
if you're a member of congress
democratic member of congress you should
get the vaccine
before people who are older ayanna
presley says that criminals should be
prioritized in getting the vaccine i kid
you not inmates should be prioritized
and then the democrats broadly say that
we should ship the vaccines
to other countries before every american
who needs one gets one
none of those standards make any sense
they're all very politically correct
ron desantis keeping it simple says i
don't think so we're going to give it to
the people who are actually at risk
so let me just be very very clear our
vaccines
are going to be targeted for our elderly
population
we've been going through over the last
week to do those tip of the sphere
health care workers
as well as our long-term care residents
and staff
that mission continues there's been a
lot of progress made on that
but as we get into the general community
the vaccines are going to be targeted
where the risk is the greatest and that
is in our elderly population
we are not going to put young
healthy workers ahead of our elderly
vulnerable population this is a coherent
argument and he's going to be opposed by
people on the left
who say how dare you older people are
predominantly white and so therefore
they're disproportionately white and
therefore you're a white supremacist if
you say that we should give
the vaccine to elderly people first i
don't care that elderly people are more
at risk for the virus you're a white
supremacist you're a racist
we need to prioritize people based on
historical injustices
and they'll redefine that by the way how
they'll they'll write up whatever they
want for what a historical injustice is
even on the matter of race they'll say
that some people aren't really right
really a certain race joe biden did this
he said if you don't vote for me then
you ain't black
they've done this to a lot of people
clarence thomas they say he's a sort of
race
or any conservative who who doesn't
happen to be white
so even even on the racial issue they
they have their own fantastical ideology
on it
but but ron desantis is going to be
called all those things
you are going to be called all of those
things
if you you want to win back the culture
you have to not be intimidated by what
the left is calling you
because it is a different standard let's
say it's the case that
you know white people are older people
are disproportionately white
it nevertheless is true that the older
people who are at risk from the virus
should get the vaccine first
that's going to be one standard that's
going to be one moral framework that's
put out there the other one is we should
just you know measure how dark a
person's skin is
and give them the vaccine based on that
that's the standard the left is putting
forward
you've got to pick one you can't have
both you have to pick one
it's not enough to say oh i don't know i
don't want to engage in this
we'll just it'll just it'll work out
we'll let the free market work it out or
we'll let
uh sort of the the randomized
distribution work it out or we'll let
the medical workers work it out no
no you need in order for it to work
you need a a framework you need a plan
this is one of the things that drives me
crazy with left-wing science
is they always say look i don't want to
get political about this what we know is
masks work
work at what we know the lockdowns work
i don't know that they work at anything
other than taking away our civil rights
and destroying the economy
but but even if you're going to say this
works
you need to say what it works for
say in order for something to work it
has to have a purpose and it has to
achieve that purpose
and it is up to us in politics to
determine what
what those purposes are to under to
understand what we are trying to achieve
the left wants to skip that and you've
got to
be able to stand up and defend a a
framework
an understanding of what politics is for
what do you think the best song of the
year is
what would you say i don't know i don't
listen to a lot of pop music there was a
great music video that came out just the
other day though it was really good
i think it was a version of please come
home for christmas i really liked it i
loved the way it sounded
maybe that but if that's not the best
song of the year what do you think would
be
well according to npr taxpayer-funded
national public radio the greatest song
of the year
you already know npr it's w.a.p it's
whap
wet peace wet
genital structure i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna say the name of the song
whap is the song of the year by cardi b
uh npr described this because
they said that it mocks the insecure
the zealots the moral grandstanders
for having the audacity to uh push back
you know it it mocks
people who are conservative it has
feminist
leanings
now i've never met any moral
grandstanders
more uh grandstanding about their
morality than the left
right the lie that they push is that
they're not
you know religious they're not uh
creating a moral framework they're just
they're just doing what works it's all
of us crazy christians
and jews and muslims we're the ones who
have these kind of crazy bible thumping
morality right but the left doesn't do
that they just have science no they they
have their own religious understanding
of the world their own moral framework
and their own moral grandstanding and if
whap is the song of the year
then that is representing a very
different moral framework than the one
that we've traditionally had
do we have the huts but do we have the
spine to stand up and say that one's
wrong
the old moral framework is right do we i
don't know here's one way we could show
that
defund npr either actually there are two
things
the first thing that would be good to do
is to take it over if i were president
today what i would do is i would use
all of the power that i had at my
disposal to
replace the executives at national
public radio
and put in people who understand things
and who understand that
whap is not the best song of the year
and then i would totally transform
national public radio and make it
actively defend the old conservative
standards
and if i couldn't do that if for
whatever reason corporate structure the
law if
i couldn't do that you know what i would
do i would defund it i would tear it
down
it is not enough for us to throw up our
hands and say oh well that you know look
that's npr for you you know that's the
new york times that's the entire
mainstream media that's big technology
that's hollywood
that's the universities that's lower
education that's the bureaucracy well
that's the whole country
that's the whole country and if you
throw up your hands
you've you've given up the entire
country
and we don't want it this sort of thing
has an effect i think for far
too long conservatives have tried to
pretend that the private realm
has no bearing on the public realm
the left understands this way better
than we do when they said in the 70s the
personal is the political they
understood
that the way that people interact
privately on the whole is going to
affect how we
how we interact publicly and that's true
you've got npr saying whap is the song
of the year this
this song that you know they say it's
wonderful for women it's empowering
it's not the song actually says that
women are prostitutes the only way
to convince a man to marry you is to
become
uh to play the role of a prostitute the
only way to keep him
engaged is to put on different wigs so
that he can think he can
convince himself that he's actually
cheating on you with another woman
so that he remains uh aroused
that is not empowering ladies cardi
cardi give me a call that is not
empowering
but that has effects in the broader
culture you've got that on npr and then
here
on the new york times you've got an
op-ed from megan nolan
who says who writes about the joys of
frivolous
sex listen to this it says
in early lockdown i spent most evenings
in the front room of my mother's house
drunk staring at a computer reeling at
the prospect
of my body being deprived indefinitely
of touch
and we can make fun of this woman for
you know this doesn't sound very
pleasant
i think a lot of people were doing that
i think especially a lot of
single people living in cities who moved
to the big city to have all these kind
of crazy
frivolous interactions they were looking
they're saying wait a second
i don't get to go out anymore i don't
get to go to the club i don't get to go
to the bar i don't get to go to a
restaurant i can't go on tinder
because of this virus is shutting down
my understanding of the world
only weeks earlier i was in new york for
an extended visit recently single
pleasantly crazy with the desire to date
far and wide
my romantic and sexual value seemed
higher then
and there than it had ever been anywhere
else my value like you're a
an object like you're a commodity i
thought it would suffer by comparison
because everyone in new york is really
hot
but it turned out my mildly manic
exuberance and complete lack of interest
in anything resembling commitment
made up for my physical shortcomings and
i imagine my irish accent didn't hurt
either
she's saying i you know i was basically
uh
it's really fun to go out with and so
guys would go out with a big surprise
i felt almost nauseated by the
overwhelming knowledge of how many
attractive people were out there
even when my dates were with guys i
would never see again i found something
in them
or the evening that i would remember
happily like the one who looked fondly
down at me in a hotel room
and exclaimed i love new york at the
sight of my body and then came the
shutdown and she goes on and complains
and says you know
in holland in one of the most completely
degenerate
leftist countries in the west in holland
they said yeah there's a virus and it's
a pandemic and we've got to shut down
all the businesses
but you should still be allowed to go
have uh casual sex
right you have to there's no way we
could say no
that shows you priorities you shut down
the churches but these people are
clamoring to have casual sex
it shows you maybe i'm i'm not even
going to you know
say that this woman i'm not going to
beat up on this woman too much you know
i think a lot of people are in the same
boat that she is however if she were
married or at least in a committed
relationship
she'd be happier right because she
wouldn't be deprived indefinitely of
touch should be happier for a lot of
other reasons too
when you look at that when you look at
the screaming girls with the blue hair
and you know some of the videos we
played this week on the show and you
read the joys of frivolous sex you got
to ask yourself do you want to be that
do you want to live like that is that is
that the kind of standard you want to
have
no i don't think it's conducive to
happiness or flourishing well then we
need to have another standard and it's
not enough to say you do you
it's it never has been in any society
you've got to
orient the society toward good things
toward
flourishing you have to have a coherent
framework
for your society and the left is denying
even that whole concept even as they
impose their own on
us we're going to have to leave this
planet i think we're gonna have to go to
another we're gonna have to colonize
mars or something like that if we want
to
set up a normal society again by the way
if you go to daily wire right now if you
go on daily wire insider or above member
with 20
you can get 20 off with code watch you
can see
apollo 11 what we saw it's not quite to
mars but it's it's about the moon
landing it's very very cool with bill
whittle
head on over that is dailywire.com
subscribe to get 20
off your membership with codewatch
access all of our new
and exciting existing content
there's this battle now between
faith religion and science and it's not
a real battle
because obviously the only reason
science developed as it did was because
of christianity
that is christianity gave birth to
science the most famous scientists in
history
uh are were christians isaac newton
devout christians spent decades of his
life interpreting scripture
uh uh george lemaitre the the guy who
discovered the big bang
was a catholic priest father george
lumetra mandel discovered genetics
catholic all these sorts of of people
however there is now in the public view
a debate between religion and science
and
what it really is a debate between
christianity and encompassed within this
kind of
traditional religion is you know judaism
islam the kind of theistic religions and
science with a capital s and what that
is
is the religion of leftism secular
liberalism which has its own maxims its
own liturgies its own rituals
its own completely irrational beliefs
and nancy pelosi just the other day on
the house floor
described this battle as much as the
left wants to say joe biden's a devout
catholic oh we love religion we support
houses of worship they don't leftism is
a rival religion
and they they look upon people who are
actually
religious christian or otherwise with
total disdain
nancy pelosi explained how in her words
we didn't do it we couldn't pass
legislation until now
because the administration simply
did not believe in testing tracing
treatment wearing masks sanitation
separation and the rest scientific
approach
it has come clear to us now that they
believed in herd immunity
quackery springing right from
the oval office and not denied
sufficiently
by some of the uh cdc and the rest
so now we have a vaccine and that gives
us hope
a vaccine that is springs from science
people say around here sometimes i'm
faith oriented
so i don't believe in signs and i said
well you can do both
science is an answer to our prayers and
our prayers have been answered
with a vaccine and in this legislation
we had provision
uh for it to be that perch develop
purchased
and distributed in a way again that is
fair
and equitable and free hold on a minute
here
i have to question a few things nancy
pelosi said
does anybody really believe that that
someone has come up to nancy pelosi and
said
i'm faith oriented and therefore i don't
believe in science
i don't think i don't think anyone's
ever said that moreover i don't know
that anyone who
who is faith-oriented has ever uttered
the phrase
faith-oriented it's it's like
in that movie the 40 year old virgin you
know steve carell's character is
explaining
what uh what breasts are like but it's
very clear he's never had any encounter
i think that's what it's like with nancy
pelosi and religious people she was yeah
she's like holding it at arm's length
people who are ugh
faith oriented is that is that a word do
you use that in the catechism i don't
know
people who are faith-oriented no that's
not what people say they say i'm
christian i'm jewish a muslim
they don't say or they say i'm leftist
i'm liberal
they don't say faith oriented and nobody
has said i'm religious therefore i don't
believe in science
what they'll say is i'm a christian and
therefore i'm morally opposed to
uh taking a vaccine that was developed
using stem cells from
aborted babies well you don't believe in
science no i believe in science
uh i believe that was a baby right i i
i'm following the scientific method i'm
inquiring as to what this physical
object how it came to be it came to be
through aborted babies
and there's something beyond the
physical it's called the metaphysical
and
there's a moral order and there i have
moral obligations and we're not just
meat puppets we're also we also are
souls and
i just think it's wrong to do that and
so i'm not going to do it and i also
believe in science because i think
there's a 99.7
chance i'll survive this virus and i
also believe in science and i know that
there is such a thing as herd immunity
despite what nancy pelosi is saying
she's calling her immunity quackery
hurt immunity has been a medical concept
for ages and ages
a well accepted medical concept it's
still it's still described on the world
health organization website even though
they keep trying to redefine it
according to the new politically correct
standards
if you're faith-oriented it's like do
you remember when hillary clinton
described there was a massacre of
christians on easter
and she didn't refer to the christians
she referred to the easter worshipers
this is a woman who has never thought
seriously about christianity ever once
in her life
she's probably thought seriously about
some leftist ideology masquerading as
christianity but no no christian refers
to
easter worshipers
and talk about believing the science
talk about believing the science
we mentioned this a little bit at the
end of the show yesterday 49
of american adults believe that the new
covid vaccine
will be safe and effective that's
according to rasmussen
which is a little right wing but it is
also a very accurate pollster
uh an even lower number 46 believe that
the new vaccine will be available in a
way that is fair to everyone
that is not the fault of the
faith-oriented or the easter worshipers
that is the fault of a medical
establishment
that has totally failed us that we do
not have faith in anymore we should not
have
faith in science generally speaking uh
even our even our own faculties of
reason are a little bit faulty you know
so we should
we should rely on them but we should
check you know we should double check
and uh we should really only have faith
in uh
god you know things that you know you
know the thing to quote our president
49 just as a purely descriptive matter
it it means that the ruling elite have
failed
if they cannot convince
the majority of americans to believe
that this vaccine is safe then they have
failed they haven't done
their job you see this in uh some of the
other experts dr scarf
is retiring you know dr dr burks was
sort of
she was the ethel to dr fauci's lucy she
was the
the robin to dr fought she's batman but
dr scarf got caught because she said
you got to cancel thanksgiving don't see
your family don't go over don't have a
good time and then she got caught seeing
her family
and she defended it by saying oh it
wasn't thanksgiving we all had dinner up
at my
my beach house you know the next day
it's the day after thanksgiving
apparently the virus
gave everyone a free pass the day after
thanksgiving no i don't think so then
her excuse was i have to go winterize my
home okay what does winterize my home
mean
it means you got to make your house
ready for winter you know so the pipes
don't freeze and all that right
most people don't have multiple homes
they've got to go winterize and that's
not a good excuse
when you're telling millions and
millions of americans
that they can't see their families they
can't celebrate
thanksgiving what does dr scorp say she
says
it's been a very difficult time it's
been tough on my family
you know my family's tried to be
supportive but they don't want to do
this
my parents had been isolated for 10
months they've been deeply depressed
and so you know i wanted to go see them
right
it's true for everybody they don't need
to be deeply depressed
we don't need to be so deeply depressed
bad things happen
i understand we're all going to deal
with suffering we don't need to make
this harder on ourselves
and and our political elites have made
this harder on ourselves and the
gullible liberals who've gone along with
it
and have made it harder on themselves
and the rest of us have been coerced
into going along with it you don't need
to do that
politics is bigger than that one thing
to look forward to in 2021 one thing
we've certainly learned from trump
we can take that politics back we
actually can exert the power that the
people give us every now and again
the politicians we elect can exert the
power that we give to them at the ballot
box
got it they have to have courage to do
that that's in short supply but we can
do that we've seen what it's like
to have a little bit of courage let's
get to the mail bag
question from michael dear swarthy
podcast host my wife and i differ
politically
i am a staunch conservative she is a
more classical
liberal with some leftist positions for
example
she likes the idea of critical race
theory but hates the idea of big
government
okay we typically have good civil
debates
the main issue that we disagree on is
abortion i have pointed out
that the low rates of rape and incest
related abortions
but she counters with the idea that a
lot of these go unreported due to fear
of backlash
she has also pointed out that members of
the military accidentally killing
civilians in other countries go
typically unpunished
okay seems like a non-sequitur but okay
ultimately she says
that as a man it is not my place to tell
a woman what to do with her body
but i say that it is not just the
woman's body at stake what are your
thoughts on this most specifically about
the two argument
arguments i mentioned uh your wife is
just dead wrong i'm sorry to say
and uh it's your your responsibility as
the head of the household to show her
that
first of all if she considers herself a
classical liberal
she really can't defend abortion the
reason for this and you know i'm not a
classical liberal i'm a conservative but
if you're a classical liberal especially
in the american tradition
then politics to you boils down to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
right
or life liberty and the protection of
property
well you can't pursue happiness or
have your property if you don't have
liberty and
you can't have liberty if you don't have
life the the right to life
according to classical liberalism is not
just one right among
many it's not you know i have a right to
go to the doctor or something if you
think about positive rights the way
people are talking about it today
uh and then i also have a right to life
no the right to life comes first and if
you're talking about the negative rights
of classical liberalism you can't have a
right to liberty without the right to
life so
the the abortion i think she should
change your position on abortion even
even from that as a matter of critical
race theory it's just
uh it's just poison to a body politic i
mean there's no
cause because you know i don't want to
oversimplify it too much but critical
theory generally
is uh the theory to criticize it it goes
back to marx's
famous description uh of his plan uh
for the ruthless criticism of all that
exists
um it's more involved in that it goes
even kookier than that but that that's
what it boils down to
and so if you are keen on these kind of
modern ideologies what they all amount
to is you've got to hate
your country your civilization the way
society is
set up you've yourself you know you
you've
you've got your religion you've just got
to hate these things um because they're
because what you're engaging in is a
radical criticism of them
uh so that's unfortunate in terms i
don't really know what she's talking
about with the uh
killings killing civilians i suppose
that
often is punished even if it does go on
punished doesn't really matter uh and
and the rape and incest issue i mean
that's
it is simply the case that uh it's less
than one percent
of abortions and by the way before roe
versus wade we were told that thousands
of women died every year from abortions
that isn't true
that the real number was double digits
and it was statistically
the same when you when you consider how
many states had legal abortion and
illegal abortion
the number of women who died from
illegal abortions was statistically
almost identical to the number of women
who died from legal abortion so all
those scientific arguments are bunk but
really you should get around the
philosophical argument
that it's just uh it's indefensible to
uh
call yourself a defender of liberty and
not defend life from howard
hey michael love the show you're the
reason i'm no longer in my libertarian
phase
love that we all go through that phase i
went through it for a long time but glad
to hear
good to be conservative that's what i
say just a question about the catholic
church i was born and raised
catholic but recently with the pope's
comments who seems to be just a leftist
in disguise
i find myself being disenfranchised with
the catholic church
also my local church hasn't been open in
months which has not helped i'm in new
york
do you think the catholic leaders will
start to stand up against the lockdowns
and start rejecting leftist sloganeering
or are we going down a path where the
church just lines up with every leftist
idea
as it seems we are i'd like some insight
as i'm quite concerned about the
direction the church is going in thanks
yeah it's frustrating we've had bad
popes before we've had plenty of bad
bishops before and some bad priests too
i'm sorry to hear you haven't gone to
mass i know that some places are
are holding public mass so if you can
find one even if you got to drive i
would recommend doing it
and some are doing it kind of on the
down low i've gone to some of those
parishes too
so i would recommend that and i'd
recommend a latin mass parish the
extraordinary form of the mass if you
can
in terms of the pope you know he said
things that trouble lots of people
sure i always go back to hilaire
bellock's line
hillary bellock was this hilariously
surly catholic writer but 100 years ago
a little more than that
and bellock said that
i am required as a catholic to take it
as a matter of faith that the
catholic church is divine however for
unbelievers a sign of its divinity
would be that no other organization
conducted with such navish imbecility
would have lasted a fortnight much less
two thousand years
and i think this is true the church has
been run poorly
forever almost forever and
it's uh a lot of the people who have
been entrusted
with power in the church and influence
have abused that power and yet
uh if you're catholic you have to
believe that is that is the one true
church and that's it that's never going
away
but we can go through very difficult
periods and it is up to the laity
to uh exercise uh respect but also
uh courage you know to stand up against
things when when they're not looking
right from frank michael thanks for your
show
i was wondering why and also how do you
put up with all the good-natured ribbing
that you are always getting from clavin
boring and shapiro and perhaps
i don't remember any instances walsh i
applaud your magnanimity you know
suffering is sanctifying i
take it all as an opportunity to become
more saintly
as i take these sorts of barbs and
jibes and then it really it kind of
started with ben
you know ben started and and that all
started because
i beat him at an election bet and then i
uh in 2016
and then i sold more blank books than he
sold real books so
one way that i make myself feel better
is i just go home every night and i sort
of stare at my framed
check signed by one mr ben shapiro
and and i just am filled with absolute
joy the only the the other
point on this though which is more broad
than the daily wire context
is men do this to one another this is
the way that men talk
i'm sure you know this as well but i'll
never forget in in college
uh where you know four or five guys
living in this
in the room and not just one bedroom but
it was kind of like a sweet type thing
and uh and i don't know one of us
brought a girl back
to introduce her to the fellas and uh
we're all sitting there
and we were all just like you stupid
idiot and you don't what you
dumb you fat you what lazy whatever you
know we're all just kind of going at
each other
and she looked at us she goes oh my god
why
why are you all so mean to each other
that's what do you mean mean
whether it's just we're buddies our guys
talk i mean how do you think guys talk
and i know these days you're like not
allowed to do it if you're if you're
tough on a guy if you go out there and
and say mean things you know it's like
bullying you're not allowed to do it but
i don't i think we'd be a better
better society if we could all do that
kind of thing a little bit more
but you know who knows that's that's
toxic masculinity if you ask the left
from annie science says influenza cases
are down because we're doing so well
masking and social distancing my
governor kate brown says
we need stricter lockdown measures and
schools must stay closed because
we're doing a terrible job masking and
social distancing
aren't we supposed to listen to the
science also why is no one
talking about the fact that case spikes
have occurred exactly as cold cases
spike in every other year thanks yeah
look there is no
doubt there is no question anymore that
the coronavirus numbers are inflated
we know that they are because county
coroners
and health officials have admitted that
that anyone who dies
with covid is counted as a death from
covid so you've heard this in many many
instances
people will be killed from a gunshot
wound
and they will be counted as a covet
death so we know for a fact that the
cases are inflated
we know for a fact there is a financial
incentive for medical institutions to
diagnose covid illnesses because they
get
more funding for that so yeah there's no
doubt
about those sorts of things uh whether
or not the
washing the hands and the masks are
working i tend to agree with dr fauci
eight months ago because i believe the
science i trust the science
and as dr fauci said the masks are
basically an ornament the masks don't
really do all that much obviously they
haven't done that much the virus is
still spreading like crazy and
everyone's wearing the masks
they can actually make it worse because
you're touching your face and you know
they're maybe they stop a droplet or two
but they're not going to stop the
infection
i generally agree with that and i i
think that
uh dr fauci who is half scientist half
politician
caved to political pressure but i tend
to believe the first thing that he said
because that is common sense and it
seems to have been borne out by the data
and the science in our dictatorship of
doctors
from sarah hey michael i'm curious what
you feel the role of women in the church
should be
in first corinthians and titus there are
many passages in scripture
explaining different expectations roles
and even positions women are allowed to
have in regard to the church
is this something that should continue
today or should we embrace a more open
and by more open i think you mean more
liberal or more modernist
idea of church duties between men and
women thanks yeah i think that should
continue to this day
i'm a catholic so you know that's how we
do it
and there have been unfortunately some
modernist infiltrations
and abuses in the liturgy that that uh
not even just for the role of women but
just broadly but yes
men priests are men
uh women should not be priests i know
that the anglican church in the 70s
decided to add priestesses to their uh
to their religion but uh catholic church
can't do it
a lot of other protestant nominations
will not do it for that same reason
this is not to say that women don't have
a role in the church or even that their
role is less spiritually important or
something like that
don't forget i mean this is something
when i hear people complain about the
feminization of the the church
usually it's more my protestant friends
who say this i see what they're talking
about
you get all the wimpy music and all the
sappy saccharine
kind of ridiculous uh liturgical abuses
and you say okay that's kind of feminine
that's not masculine
but likewise let's not forget that the
the image that we have of the church is
that christ is the bridegroom
and the church is the bride we are all
the bride of christ in the church
that's a very feminine idea for
especially catholics and
eastern orthodox and anglicans to an
extent mary plays a very important role
the way that we pray the rosary the way
that we sort of try to view
through mary's eyes uh that you wouldn't
call that masculine right you'd call
that feminine
but just as we talk about in modern
gender theory you don't want
men to become women and women to become
men they can't do that and so
i think there are plenty of roles for
women in the church they can be nuns for
instance i know that's now considered
shocking
that anyone would choose a religious
life but a nuns good good place for
women to be um but they can't be priests
and that's that's the way it is because
men and women are different and i think
if you if you approach this matter as
i've heard even some
uh catholics say well why not i we
deserve to be priests we deserve
i think you're approaching it from the
wrong way this is you ought to approach
it from a position of
humility and of duty and obligation what
can i do how can i serve how
can i beserve this is not about
grandiosity i once once heard a homily
where a priest said that you know
sometimes uh
people would want to in a catholic
procession you have
the people carrying the cross up the
aisle and then
that goes in order of importance all the
way back to the priest or even the
bishop or even the pope would be further
back
and that this priest said that sometimes
these younger
you know members in the church would try
to go back to see more important where
the priests and the bishops were
and this priest said those men should
pray to have the humility to stand under
the cross and pray that the blood of
christ drops on their heads
so that they can understand humility and
you know it's a very uh graphic way of
putting it
uh but i think that's how we should
approach the church not from a position
of entitlement
and feeling that we are owed something
but uh
from the humble desire to serve from
aiden
mr knowles my college just announced
that for the spring semester covid
testing will be mandatory every two
weeks for faculty staff and students
masking and social distancing were
required on pain of expulsion for the
fall semester even though there were no
outbreaks on campus
now they're taking it further by
mandating medical testing i don't think
i signed over my medical rights when i
decided to attend a public university
would love to get your thoughts on this
he who pays the piper calls the tune my
friend i think what's going on
at your school is absolutely terrible i
think it's not going to stop until we
all
stop until we all fight back but he who
pays the piper calls the tune the state
runs your university the state's going
to tell you what to do
this is true by the way when people talk
about free education free college they
want the government to pay for college
what that amounts to is a government
takeover
of even the private universities which
bad as they are could get a whole
lot worse in that scenario which is why
we all ought to pray
we all ought to enjoy one another's
company we all ought to ignore these
stupid lockdown rules
we all ought to have a very very merry
christmas because even amid all of this
madness and unfortunate turns of events
and politics which always happen
we have a lot to be grateful for we even
have a lot to be grateful for in the
struggle you know the great saints of
history have prayed to live in times
such as these
because there's such opportunity for
sanctity merry christmas
happy new year see you in january
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there